تقع [الموسيقى]
بعيدًا في جبال تركيا الشمالية ،
وهي قرية نائية حيث يتحدث بعض السكان
لغة خاصة ، وهي لغة فولاذية
هادئة تُعرف أيضًا باسم لغة الطيور ،
فهي تتيح محادثات معقدة عبر
مسافات طويلة دون استخدام كلمات
مستوحاة من هذه القصة الكبيرة الرائعة من Genesis
[موسيقى  ]
[موسيقى]
أريكة الأم التي ستعيشها الأم
هل يمكن أن تزدهر بشكل لا يطاق في مات
تقول إنه يُعرف باسم Whistler الأعظم
في قريتها لعدة قرون قام المزارعون في
Cusco بتربية الماشية وأنتجوا
محاصيل مختلفة بدأوا في الأصل
باستخدام لغة الطيور حتى يتمكنوا من ذلك
بسرعة  يتواصلون مع بعضهم البعض
فوق التلال بينما يعملون بشكل جيد ،
تبدو رائعًا ، لديك أحد كبار السن في نورث
أفينيو يقومون بعمل آخر بالحافلات ،
الطفل ناجانو اليابان صغير ، وحتى
أنهم يعطونهم يحتاجون إلى راوي هو
كيبوش في لوس أنجلوس ، أريد أن أرى ، أعرف أن لوجان
نشأ مصطفى  على غرار شفرة مورس ،
تحول لغة الطيور
المفردات التركية الكاملة إلى
ترددات نغمات متنوعة وخطوط لحنية
wha  قد يكون هناك رقم ماخ مع مقيِّم
بطاقة Hubble Washburn McLaren College ،
تتمتع شقة مزرعة Boola المستقبلية ، التي لم يتم
تحصيل رسوم منها على نطاق واسع في المناقشة في
النظام الأساسي تحت حكم توماس ميسا
الاقتصادي في فيتنام ، كل يوم نحن بصدد الصواريخ
في مكانها ولكن بين التوقفات
المال هي إنجلترا بوذا لكن لغة الطيور
تختفي ببطء ، أنا متأكد من
أنها حصلت عليها كومي ، عادة ما قالوا
إنها ستتأخر إلى
أن تحصل إيفانا على شوكولاتة سلبية ، تريد الموز أن
يظهر لي الكثير ، لكن مات يقول إن الصفير
لا يزال ينطلق بقوة من
منطاد العسل Majesty  من شأنه أن يسلم
سمًا طالبًا قميًا يكون مسلمًا يعطي
آلان دي بوتون في غرفة كولومبوس شديدة الذكاء حتى
عليه أضاف سامي أوه تحته
[موسيقى]